published in the lancet it's called
community transmission and viral load
kinetics of the sarsko v2 delta
b.1.617.2 variant in vaccinated and
unvaccinated individuals in the uk a
prospective longitudinal cohort study
we're going to say a few things about
this but let me just go right
here first interpretation
vaccination reduces the risk of delta
variant infection and accelerates viral
clearance
nonetheless
fully vaccinated individuals with
breakthrough infections have peak viral
load similar to unvaccinated cases and
can efficiently transmit infection in
household settings including to fully
vaccinated contacts host virus
interactions early in infection may
shape the entire viral trajectory
so i may have my screen back zachary
thank you sweetie um
additional takeaways from this work
before we talk about what um
what this means uh there's two other
pieces of work that they cite uh which i
was not aware of they cite work out of
singapore which found that only eight
percent of coveted cases and
unvaccinated people were with the delta
variant
whereas the delta is representing nearly
all the coveted cases among the
vaccinated
that's fascinating right that's
fascinating
um apparently households are indeed the
site of most sarsko v2 transmission
globally
and you know we've been this has been
one of our drum beats from the beginning
you're sending sick people home to their
to their families where they can and
probably will infect them well yes that
is that is what the policy has been and
apparently that is the site at which
most of the
when it has been looked at where are
people getting sick most people are
getting sick from covet in their homes
from other people in their homes
but with regard to the present study two
additional uh two additional results
are that peak viral load did not differ
by vaccination status or variant type
okay but did increase modestly with age
so again something that suggests um
excuse me
possibly why
my people may be getting sicker as they
are older when they are infected with
covid
and
finally to a question about which i want
to spend a little bit more time in the
present study they found that the risk
of infection increased with time in the
two to three months since the second
dose of the vaccine
so let me just say that again
um and also let's let's just point out
that um
across every study that i've seen and
all of the public health pronouncements
the numbers are being juked in so many
ways um but one of the ways is that
you're not you're not called fully
vaccinated until you are two weeks out
from your final from your final jab
and that means that a whole lot of stuff
can happen in those first in those first
two weeks and indeed in the you know not
the first two weeks in the you know the
first you know month or more between the
moment that you have your first shot if
it's an mrna shot for which you're
expected to have two and after the two
weeks after you've got your second one
and so none of the things that happened
to you in that time um do you fall into
vaccinated status
um so that's that's one thing um so we
have this firm set point that has been
uh that has been handed to us without
any explanation as to why
that you are only considered fully
vaccinated
two weeks after
and what these people what these
researchers find is that uh in two to
three months within two to three months
your immunity is waning which is to say
your risk of infection is rising
so
this raises questions
again again and again and again for me
about what it means to be vaccinated
right um if
you're losing
immunity two to three months after your
after your final uh vaccine
at what moment
really can you claim to be fully
vaccinated we've got this this beginning
set point we get this beginning point
and no one's told us an end point we're
now being encouraged to do boosters if
you've already had your first ones
but um it's illegitimate to have a start
point and no end point you know really
after two or three months now we have
we're seeing in this study and across
many studies that you're simply not as
protected as as you were and so what
does it even mean to be
fully vaccinated and let me just say
before before you we jump in here
i want to consider
the rabies vaccine in our experience
with the rabies vaccine we were
vaccinated with against rabies uh in the
90s when you were doing a lot of bat
work and this is a prophylactic vaccine
yes that you get if you think you may
encounter rabies so people like
veterinarians get it right veterinarians
and i mean vaccine is prophylaxis
um right there's
an inoculation that you get famously if
you've contracted rabies if you have
contacted rabies but that's not a
vaccine yeah right so we were we we both
sought out the rabies vaccine
in the 90s when you were working with
bats and i was working with you
sometimes actually i'm not technically
certain that what you get after
contact with rabies isn't a vaccine i
will have to look into its exact
mechanism and then i think it's it's not
a simple question but it may it may be
that you're right and i just
don't okay um i don't
semantically to me
vaccines suggest prophylaxis which is to
say before exposure but perhaps this is
perhaps this is not right so we were
both uh we were both vaccinated against
rabies in the 90s and at the time they
told us you know we said okay this is
lifelong because some of the some of the
vaccines you get are considered
lifelong and they said you know maybe
in 10 years or so if you're still doing
the work that is putting you at risk of
exposure uh then you should consider
getting your titers checked so like
tetanus
like technologies
right and and indeed a lot of these
things which are actually childhood
vaccines at the point that you are an
adult you may get your last shot and
they will say um you know in 10 years
you'll be due again this is true for
yellow fever as well like yellow fever
and rabies being vaccines that you know
we're vaccinated against
but most most people aren't because most
people most weird people most people in
the u.s for instance don't go to places
where they will be exposed to the to the
pathogen um but we had our tires checked
10 years on and our our titers happened
to be fine so we never got um a booster
but the idea of a booster 10 years on
makes some sense because immunity will
wane and um there are a lot of things
that your immune system is doing and if
it hasn't been exposed
to the pathogen in question in 10 years
then maybe it has maybe your body has
lost some of its immunity
the idea of a vaccine
that is
effective only against some variants and
not very effective against
against delta even at the beginning and
begins to lose its efficacy within two
or three months
of being so-called vaccinated
raises for me the question of what
counts as a vaccine at this point
yeah this is
first of all they are playing on
the
lack of biological sophistication of the
public right the public does know more
or less in some vague sense what an
antibody is and therefore it can
understand something like what a titer
is and it can understand these things as
a proxy but the idea that what's being
generated by these vaccines and we can
argue about whether or not that's even a
fair term in light of the mechanism of
action
but what they are
producing is b-cell immunity they're
producing antibodies what we want is we
want t cell immunity
and so we are seeing the failure and
again is there a technological marvel
that doesn't make them safe right their
technological mark marvel they do work
to some extent but basically they are in
your words their prototype they're a
prototype and you know the other term
which i think we haven't used yet uh i
say this as somebody who um
i've done less of it recently but i used
to tinker and invent things and there's
a stage called proof of concept right
yeah where you have some
object that took you
so long to build that it can't possibly
be regarded as as a success in terms of
solving the problem it's targeted at but
it does prove that the problem can be
solved so you having produced this you
know monstrosity
will be delighted as its inventor that
yes the problem is solvable and i've
figured out step one of how to do it but
it's not something you could bring to
market or you would inflict on somebody
right and this is what we've got is
we've got proof that you can vaccinate
against this disease
at what
cost in terms of risk to a person and to
what level of effectiveness immunity
that wanes at this level we're basically
dealing with something that's the analog
of the gamma globulin shots
that people used to get for maybe they
still do get
uh for malaria where you know you can
get some antibodies that will you know
probably gum up the malaria if it gets
into your system but it only let you
know but because you're not producing
them
it's a it's a very short-lived kind of
protection i think the first time that
we traveled into the tropics we got we
got the gamma globulin i've certainly
had it i can't and then it was
prophylactic's different prophylaxis
including chloroquine
right
um but the uh
the fact of
this
so first of all this game and you're
right about the juking of the stats in
some sense this pandemic has a meta
pandemic of
fraudulent accounting that goes with it
the idea that there's any debate at all
about what vaccinated means who the
unvaccinated are or what does it mean to
be fully vaccinated no no
are you vaccinated well
did somebody put a needle in your arm
and inject the stuff you're vaccinated
to the extent of the vaccines are you
protected right different questions
right are you immunized maybe we could
use that term and we can say actually
you're not immunized until weeks out but
you're vaccinated but if we start
talking about immunity
then we're not just going to have to
also talk about acquired immunity from
actually having survived covid
but also
especially if there does turn out to be
this causal link between vitamin d
deficiency and kovid
if your vitamin d levels are sufficient
don't you kind of have immunity to covid
and
you know it's not perfect right it's not
perfect but then neither are the
vaccines there is no perfect solution
here right and you know we have many
categories and you know
garrett vandenbosch uh is focused on
innate immunity which is different than
natural immunity natural immunity being
generated in response to the disease
innate immunity being the kind of
immunity that mostly protects most of us
from most things most of the time right
it's the kind of immunity that you have
there i mean innate versus acquired in
the in the immune system sense as
opposed to i just used maybe maybe i
confused the terminology by saying
acquired by which i'm from from a
disease i think you got it right no i
know i got but i think i think that you
just spoke in a way that was maybe
confusing well let's put it this way i
think to the layperson's ear innate and
natural immunity sound alike and they
refer to two different things right so
the fact that
kids fend off this disease pretty well
gerd vandenbosch at least
ascribes to their innate immunity yeah
and the point is these systems interact
so at the point that you're buying uh
vaccine-based immunity you may be buying
it at some cost to innate immunity and
you may be compromising the system's
ability to generate natural immunity
because of something called uh
original antigenic sin
right original antigenic sin sin meaning
that when your immune system has seen a
pathogen it already is part it becomes
trained on the path for the solution
which means that to the extent that some
other solution might be better it's not
available because the immune system is
like i got this one i know
right it becomes canal exactly
and so anyway all of these things trade
off against each other and in a healthy
environment we would have people hard at
work at figuring out what those
trade-offs were and for whom it was
worth making that gamble by healthy
environment you mean a healthy
scientific and political environment
right and a scientific and political
environment in which doctors and
scientists were free to say what they
were seeing to say what they thought it
meant and why and to fight it out right
honorably and we don't live in that
environment at all we live in an
environment where we've been told the
answer and we are going to have people
insist on that answer and what's more
they're going to demonize anybody who
says wait a minute i know that answer
isn't right and here's how right those
people become
villains and you know who else becomes
villains
the unvaccinated even if the
unvaccinated have complied and had a
vaccine right that has to do with the
fraudulent way that that term is being
used
right the idea that you're fully
vaccinated at the point that you're
weeks out from your second vaccination
rather than at the point that you have
complied means that we've created this
phony category people who have complied
but remain vulnerable because the
vaccines are a disappointment are being
shoved into this other mythological
category in order that they can be
demonized so people will rush toward the
vex opposite but yes
well people who who've complied are
being demonized in the data they're
being claimed to have resisted the
vaccine and that's why they're safe and
that's why they're sick right
to the extent that somebody who is one
week out from their second vaccination
come down comes down with the disease
and then they show up in a data set as
unvaccinated and sick with kovid it
sounds like those are the people you're
talking about right those people
sound like they have been
resistant
and not done what they were asked to do
and that's why they're sick when in fact
the reason that they're sick is that
there's an immunological process that
has to unfold and that in fact
i mean if you think about it
the way that this works
the disease itself
and your first vaccination
cause the development of immunity at the
point that you are vaccinated again
that immunity interacts with your
vaccine right it cannot help but do so
to the extent that the second time you
get vaccinated with one of these things
some new crop of cells starts
putting out the antigen
the cells that are built to recognize
that antigen will do that and they will
start bonding to the antigen either
sticking off the surface of these cells
that are now making it or floating
around because the anchoring domain
didn't work and the point is that is
going to have an effect on how immune
you actually are at that moment if you
encounter a person sick with covid so
you know this isn't
this is straightforward right this
problem exists what is its effect on a
person's actual level of protection and
what advice which should we therefore
give them and how should they show up in
a table that tells us
where you're protected and where you're
not this feels very very abstract what
advice we should give them in part is
immediately after vaccination you're
actually a particular risk
that that that is actually the moment
when you should be most careful not to
be exposed uh to the disease right and
we uh we we give no such advice right we
at best say something like you're not
fully protected till rather than you're
actually in a special state
[Music]
you